all right let's talk about facebook
because during the show yesterday there
was this capitol hill hearing we had a
facebook whistleblower and as i said
yesterday it kind of sounded good she
was saying they're doing all sorts of
things they're manipulating us in all
sorts of ways and they're making us all
angry and western civilization is
collapsing because of the like button
and all that stuff and it was a bunch of
stuff that we kind of knew and we all
sort of can see and we know this stuff
isn't making us happy like we open apps
and we're all angrier than before like
something ain't right we all kind of
know that
but then the hearing started taking a
turn because she suddenly started
prescribing things for the government to
do and that doesn't really sound like a
whistleblower whistleblower would be
like
here's a bunch of info uh they're up to
bad stuff that mean mark zuckerberg and
those big tech guys uh here's the stuff
i'm at a hearing but suddenly she
started saying but this is what you got
to do about it that's a very different
thing well now the story's starting to
change first we've got a little bit of
video of francis is her name francis
haagen is that right francis hogan
facebook has demonstrated they cannot
act independently facebook over and over
again has shown it uses profit over
safety it is subsidizing is paying for
its profits with our safety i'm hoping
that this will have had a big enough
impact on the world
that they get the fortitude and the
motivation to actually go put those
regulations into place
uh okay so you can see she's sort of
saying there's some bad stuff here and
maybe there's some ways we can deal with
it all right so again it doesn't sound
like that awful it's a little weird
whatever now we've got some info from
the daily wire here on uh on hoggin uh
hoggin suggested that congress could
make facebook liable for promoting
content based on engagement rather than
on accuracy or any number of factors so
that's just her opinion on what maybe
facebook or what the government in
essence could do hoggin quote has a
record of donations to far left
democrats and a history of raising
issues about purported bias while at
previous employers she is working with
democrat operatives to roll out her
complaint and has the same lawyers as
the anonymous ukraine whistleblower
whose allegations led to donald trump's
impeachment but who reportedly turned
out to be then vice president joe
biden's top advisor in the country okay
now this is starting to get a little
weird the daily wire continues she's
also represented by a company called
bryce and gillette helmed by a raft of
democratic operatives who are providing
hogan with strategic communications
guidance and helping run what one
republican called an incredibly well
orchestrated communications campaign the
free beacon reported burton is on the
board for the center of humane
technology which has waged a policy war
with facebook white house press
secretary jen saki worked at one point
with bryce and gillette with the center
for humane technology as one of her
clients
okay so this is sort of interesting
we're getting a sense here that maybe
she is not exactly just some average
employee at facebook who had some
concerns and by the way when you
suddenly end up on 60 minutes a few days
after like these things don't happen
by happenstance you know like the way
the industry works if you're going to
get on these tv shows there are
publicists involved right like i had a
book out like publicists get you on tv
shows or can't get you on tv shows for
example when my book came out i was able
to get on every fox show i was able to
get on every sort of center right thing
but my publicists at penguin the biggest
book publisher out there could not get
me on any cnn or msnbc shows because the
things that i talk about are against the
narrative that they want out there i'm
using that as an example because she
suddenly she goes okay facebook is bad
government better get involved and then
next thing you know she's on
a major news magazine show 60 minutes
and it's like oh so what what narrative
right like i know i know you guys get it
but this is the idea that we've got to
get across to our friends who are
confused
about why we are on this slow descent to
hell the mainstream machine crafts a
narrative very carefully this is how
they launder the lies so she says
something at a hearing right then it
kind of works it way up it's way up to
60 minutes it becomes sort of mainstream
zeitgeist then we get more politicians
suddenly saying okay
we should censor these things and of
course the irony is i'm not sitting here
telling you that facebook and twitter
and youtube and the rest of them are so
great they're pretty awful
they're pretty awful imagine if you had
a problem with your gmail account is
there anyone you could get on the phone
right absolutely not twitter banned me
back in july for saying that vaccine
mandates were coming okay these are
horrible companies and at some level i
pity them because they became too big
and they're run by leftist incompetent
morons because they believe more in
diversity than truth and that is going
to create a situation where you're going
to have a lot of bad things happening
and a bunch of people at your companies
who don't know what to do
but none of that is an excuse to them be
like okay government only if the
government could now censor facebook
more would be the answer but that's what
the machine wants the machine wants more
censorship
on these platforms and that's why i've
been saying for a while we have to be
careful what we ask for section 230 that
offers these big tech platforms
protections so that they can't be sued
for the content that goes on their
platforms once you revoke that which i
understand the inclination to revoke it
okay we're going to revoke that they
don't deserve any protections but then
what will they do they will suddenly be
like oh we have to censor more stuff
because we don't want to end up in
lawsuits that's why this whole thing is
so freaking messy well mark zuckerberg
who is the chief cylon droid over at uh
facebook he responded uh to some of the
comments made during the hearing
yesterday this is from the hill mark
zuckerberg responded to testimony a
facebook whistleblower gave to congress
on tuesday if we didn't care about
fighting harmful content then why would
we employ so many more people dedicated
to this than any other company in our
space even ones larger than us i don't
know what companies larger than facebook
but okay if we wanted to hide our
results why would we have established an
industry-leading standard for
transparency and reporting on what we're
doing he went on to say a bunch of other
things like that basically like we're
doing everything we can i don't know
exactly how evil facebook is but i know
the government's evil and i know that
the more the government gets involved
the more they will suppress thought